la economía china crecerá un 6 este año
la ha pronosticado esta mañana el primer
ministro lee que chan durante la
inauguración de la asamblea nacional
popular o parlamento chino es un
pronóstico conservador porque los
expertos internacionales lo habían
fijado en el 8% pero bastará por un lado
para sellar el regreso de la normalidad
y por el otro para confirmar a china
como la locomotora en la recuperación
global tras la pandemia del coronavirus
el discurso del iii ha tenido un perfil
muy económico se ha comprometido a crear
11 millones de puestos de trabajo
urbanos 2 millones más que el año pasado
y ha aludido a una de las mayores
amenazas para la economía china la baja
natalidad que sigue en caída libre a
pesar de que varios años atrás se derogó
la política del hijo único es por eso
que muchos analistas confían en que
pekín durante esta semana levante las
últimas restricciones también se ha
sabido hoy que la asamblea debatirá y
con toda probabilidad aprobará la nueva
reforma electoral de hong kong para
evitar que los elementos que pekín
califica
subversivos se cuelen en el parlamento
la reforma contempla un comité electoral
que haga una labor previa de filtrado
para evitar que la oposición pueda
participar